it's time for this week's pet project
lori heron joins us from nspca
and uh this week we've got something
other than a dog
and a cat right lori that's right
kendall
this is anna the guinea pig because it's
adopt a rescue
guinea pig fund and many people out
there don't know that nevada spca in
addition to dogs and cats
also has a small mammals room which i'm
in right now i'm actually sitting in a
guinea pig hutch
and i'm with two beautiful little girls
that are
named after the frozen characters anna
and elsa
and this is anna you can see that she's
beautiful calico
guinea pig she is bonded with another
guinea pig alpha
who i can try to pick up here in a
minute but he's a little bit more shy
when it comes to the television
they're bonded we usually recommend that
guinea pigs go out in pairs
and you know what kendall they are often
overlooked but an amazing first pet
for families i can see some little girls
out there that are crazy about the
frozen movies that would be
excellent families for these little guys
and
they are easy to care for just some hay
and healthy vegetables they actually are
very communicative they make noises they
actually purr like
a cat when they're happy and they're
really sweet
um so i would recommend a guinea pig for
a first time pet for our families out
there and
we could tell you more about it at
nevada spca
yeah good for families with limited
space as well
absolutely absolutely and we have a
partnership with an amazing
um company called guinea dad that
donates
all of our wonderful guinea pig supplies
and we can get we can
tell you more about them and what what
you'll need to take home your guinea pig
for as far as pens and
bedding and pay and again a really easy
pet to take care of and
one that a lot of families out there
watching today would enjoy
yeah anna there looks like a sweetheart
appreciate it lori very much
thanks kendall if you're interested in
adopting a pet you can go to
nevadaspca.org starting tomorrow you can
call them 702-873-7722 to schedule a
time to go meet anna and elsa